en sus propias palabras sanier no es una
escritora autos sociobiográfica también
feminista y la academia sueca le ha
otorgado el premio Nobel de literatura
por el coraje y la perspicacia clínica
con la que descubre las raíces la
lejanía y las limitaciones colectivas de
la memoria personal
con más de una veintena de libros
escritos su escritura ha hecho énfasis
en la intimidad y sus propios
pensamientos y quizás el verdadero
objetivo de mi vida sea este que mi
cuerpo mi sensaciones y mis pensamientos
se conviertan en escritura es decir en
algo inteligible y general y que mi
existencia pase a disolverse
completamente en la cabeza y en la vida
de los otros
ha sido considerada como una guardiana
de la memoria escogemos nuestros objetos
y lugares de memoria o más bien el
espíritu de la época decide que merece
ser recordado además de escribir
sociología literaria con énfasis en sus
propios orígenes de clase trabajadora
nunca pensé que las diferencias
provinieran del dinero creía que era
algo innato la pulcritud o la mugre el
gusto por las cosas bonitas o la dejadez
las borracheras el fiambre enlatado el
papel de periódico enganchado a un clavo
junto al retrete creía que era una
elección que eran felices así hacen
falta un montón de reflexiones lecturas
clases para no pensar de esa manera
sobre todo cuando se es una niña y
siempre ha sido así tanto en sus libros
como en sus declaraciones siempre se ha
mostrado abiertamente feminista así
habló en una entrevista de archivo para
France 24
ha habido siempre fuerzas reaccionarias
para querer mantener el cuerpo de las
mujeres porque es de eso que se trata de
mantener el cuerpo de las mujeres bajo
la voluntad y la mirada de los hombres
él no es la decimoséptima mujer en la
historia en recibir un premio Nobel de
literatura mientras que ya son 16 los
franceses que han recibido el galardón
en toda la historia